first of all i love this movie so much i
was giggling so much and then by the end
i was super emotional crew i know you
you wrote the screenplay for this where
did the idea for this movie come from
well i i wanted to i write to figure out
something and so um
i um
i wanted to figure out success
and what it looks like and what it would
feel like and why i wanted it and
why i wasn't getting it and um i so i
just i landed on my answer which was
like for me success looks like dolly
parton
she she's beautiful and she's sexy and
she's
creative and
talented and all the things that we love
about dolly parton but she's a business
woman and i sort of felt i mean i'm
certainly no dolly parton but i felt
little affiliations with her um and this
was sort of over 10 years ago so that's
where i started
i started
wanting to
explore success
and via dolly parton
i love that rose for you was this an
immediate yes to to be an executive
producer on this to want to become elvis
what was your whole process like
well crew wrote the screenplay started
working on it you know over a decade ago
and
at that time we
we
we were kind of looking at other friends
of ours who'd started you know film
production companies and we thought why
don't we just start a company and we'll
try to see if that will help get this
film made and so we joined
forces with some other friends of ours
jess carrera who's a producer gracie
otto who is the director of seriously
red and shannon murphy a director and
producer and writer and we started
dollhouse pictures and so this was
really the impetus to start the the
company and then it's been this you know
journey of the last 10 years to um to
get it made and it finally came together
and in 2020 of all years um in this
window in australia when bobby and i
were in
we're in australia shooting and uh we we
got the film made you know it was it was
pretty a while it's been a very wild
ride and now we're here at south by
southwest so it's been it's very
emotional to be here and very thrilling
and exciting and you know it's truly an
independent film
and it has that spirit about it and that
kind of sense of uh
kind of camaraderie i think yeah
absolutely okay so i want to know
between the two of you who is the bigger
dolly parton fan
who is the bigger elvis fan
uh uh
i'm probably the well
i know what i don't know i mean
bob my bobby is my bobby bobby's such an
elvis fan and when we were
when i was crew pitched me out the idea
to do elvis i just
was so thrilled by it and just immersed
myself in his footage and but but
bobby's already kind of been obsessed
with him for a long time so
it was it felt it felt like a real
um kind of culmination of all of that
for me
and i'm probably the bigger big bigger
dolly fan yeah yeah
the dolly fan so would you say that
bobby was your biggest
critique when it came to how you were
impersonating elvis
yes he i don't think he really saw it
until i was actually up there and i
think he just thought it was hysterical
he was just laughing
it's so good so did you prove his neil
diamond
portrayal yes i was very critical well
he often sings neil diamond he does a
lot of karaoke with his friends and
he'll often sing a neil diamond track so
that that tracked very well for him that
was like
that's amazing it was such a good moment
in the movie so crew i loved watching
you you impersonate dolly like at the
beginning of the film and then you know
just look wise just got so good towards
the end what was the most challenging
part about impersonating dolly
um what
i mean physically i had to get like
dolly fit
um it took me a little while just with
like the corsets and the and the
prosthetics and the um the wigs
and the makeup um the first few days i
felt like i couldn't really eat much
food and um
and i had like a kind of a constant like
migraine i'm just in the bed wigs
um so i was like yeah i'm getting dolly
fit getting nearly fit um but by the end
of it i really missed it and i kind of
sometimes
would take off the outfits and go
yeah
i mean cassie hanlon who was the um
designer of all the the wigs and the
makeup looks
she's such a a craft woman and she's
been in the game for so long so
um it was she did an incredible job you
know i think that's why she got on board
because it was actually a job she could
really create with
um
so yeah she just we were like whatever
you want to do
go for it and she did so and the same
with all the costumes tim chapel also
forced to be reckoned with he um he just
explodes with creativity and ideas and
um he just
ran with it and
uh it was just a thrill to watch
everyone in their element just going for
it yeah yeah
absolutely it's i mean such a huge part
of the success of this film um is it
true that dolly gave you thumbs up on
making this movie
yes
yes
see i mean like as in the last few days
she has on some of her social media
posts which is like i can't even i can't
even but um yeah we approached her
really early because we really couldn't
have made the film without
all of her um music and rose was
instrumental with
uh
making that happen and connecting with
dolly's manager who's also an ep on the
film um
yes yeah i approached danny nozzle you
know i was like six months pregnant and
i drove from atlanta where i was
shooting neighbors too all the way to
nashville and we had a meeting and i
pitched in the movie and gave him a
script and
we you know he i
he was he was an incredibly generous guy
danny and he quickly took it to dolly
and we got her blessing very soon after
that and he helped us get the music and
all the things i mean we literally would
not be here without danny because he he
he made that happen and you can't tell
this story without the music and you
know
and you wouldn't want to tell it without
dolly's blessing anyway so it's been
that's been very special incredible for
us
now i know you have her support but do
you know if she's seen the movie yet
she has she has yeah oh good okay that's
amazing
i mean crew what's that like for you
it's so weird it's so
surreal it's surreal and then i also
like think about her and her headspace
and she must find it so
strange like if i ever get to meet her
i'll just have to say like don't be
weird about it we just made a film about
you don't worry about it don't don't be
weird
just let us love you
i know exactly she's so humble she is
just such an extraordinary example of
yeah yes isn't she yeah
she seems that way and i mean this movie
is such a beautiful tribute to her and
and so i can't imagine how much she
would just like love this movie if you
could impersonate any musician other
than elvis or dolly who do you think you
would try to take on
musician
[Laughter]
i'd probably have to go with someone
like
share
oh oh yeah yeah talk about costumes oh
yeah yeah someone who's like kind of
really different from me but
you get to experience
the costumes and yeah and then the eras
yeah
yeah totally
yeah do you want to be sure too i would
like to be like david byrne
you know from talking heads
incredible he's incredible but barbara
our kids are obsessed with him and i'm
just obsessed with his show on broadway
american youtubers think he's amazing
and he all the error different errors
he's had like he's he's always played
with
such great um ideas in his work as an
artist and yeah
so good um and we don't have the same
last name i was just gonna say so
which i said to him when we met and he
was like
you know
who are you
[Laughter]
same name
i kind of wish i was there now for that
moment
okay so i know this is a tricky question
because not only are there such great
dolly quotes throughout the movie in the
music do you have a favorite dolly
parton song
jolene i know it's so good
yeah it's it's i mean yeah
i love nine to five i love festival so
much
my kids really like it too now because
it's in back to the outback there's
netflix kids moving on netflix and they
love it they love the song it's oh my
god it's a
it's just such a hot track yeah
i mean you can strut to it yeah you
really can i'd like a song with a stripe
a new strutting song
beyonce can i just put that out there to
beyonce maybe lucy's lizzo's lizzie
linda oh great yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like that just putting it out there
uh well congratulations on the movie uh
like i said not only was i emotional at
parts but i was giggling so much it was
so good um congratulations for having at
the festival big deal thank you thank
you thanks for your support
you